[موسيقى]
أمستردام ، مدينة الدراجات
والقنوات في رحلة لتصبح
مدينة مواصلات نظيفة في العقد القادم ،
تخطط عاصمة هولندا
لخفض الانبعاثات إلى الصفر في مكتب العمدة ،
تبدأ المرحلة الأولى الآن في هذه
اللحظة لدينا تسعة أماكن  في مدينتنا
غير مؤهل حتى
للوائح الأوروبية المتعلقة بجودة الهواء ، نريد أن نكون
مدينة صحية بحلول عام 2030 وهذا يعني
ثورة في الطريقة التي ننظم
بها تنقلنا ، فالمستقبل كهربائي
لتحقيق ذلك يتضمن فتح آفاق جديدة
قريبة من 1000 عملية شحن
يتم تثبيت النقاط في الشوارع ، حيث
تلعب شركة الطاقة النظيفة Vattenfall
دورًا رئيسيًا في البنية التحتية ، تخيل
100000 سيارة كهربائية في المدينة
وجميعهم يريدون الشحن في نفس الوقت ، ثم
سيتعطل كل شيء وهذا ما
نريد منع حدوثه لذلك
هذا هو  لماذا اخترعنا مشروع الطاقة المرنة ،
لذلك إذا كان هناك طلب كبير على
الطاقة في منطقة معينة في شارع معين ،
فإننا نخفض سرعة شحن
أعمدة الشحن في تلك المنطقة المحددة
إذا كان هناك فائض من
الطاقة المتجددة مثل يوم مشمس جدًا ،
فيمكننا زيادة سرعة الشحن ،
فنحن أول
من نطلق هذا على نطاق واسع في
العديد من خدمات سيارات الأجرة والسائق
أصبحت كهربائية ولكن بسعر يبدأ من
25000 دولار ، لا يستطيع معظم مالكي السيارات الخاصة
تحمل تكلفة التبديل في نهاية المطاف
، سيكون لديهم عائلة واحدة لديها
حل مشاركة السيارة بين الأسر ، لذلك
أعتقد أن والدي هو الذي توصل
إلى فكرة أننا نفعل كل شيء من خلال  الدراجة ونحن
نستخدم السيارة فقط لمثل مرة واحدة أو
مرتين في الشهر ، حيث انخفضت تكاليفها الشهرية
من ستمائة إلى مائتي دولار ،
يساعد استئجار مكان وقوف السيارات هذا في
التوفير - بشكل عام ، فإن خطة تقليل
الانبعاثات إلى الصفر بحلول عام 2030 تتوقف على
تحول إضافي في  صناعة السيارات ،
نحتاج إلى سيارات كهربائية مستعملة ،
لذا نحاول تنظيم مناقشة مع
صناعة السيارات ، على سبيل المثال ،
الشركة الأقل كيف يمكننا تنظيم ذلك
إذا كانت  rs تباع وتكون
أرخص ومتاحة للأشخاص الآخرين
الذين يريدون شراء سيارة كهربائية
John deuf Terius CNN Amsterdam